can the Prime Minister give an example  of her making a mistake apologizing for  it properly and fixing it  Mr Speaker there's been a number of  occasions where we acknowledge that we  will not have perfect responses we've  openly uh Mr Speaker we've openly uh  said that for instance miq was something  that was very difficult at the time and  that there were people uh affected by it  and that we would do things differently  were we ever confronted with that again  but Mr Speaker I stand by the work that  we've done as a government over this  last year and over this past term we've  always made decisions that we believe to  be in the best interests of New Zealand  at the time  uh question number five Nicola Willis